die leute sind in einer bar
ich fahre mit dem bus die leute sind im
kino kann ich mit karte bezahlen
ich trainiere oft im fitnesscenter
zeigen sie bitte ihr flüchtig ich fliege
mit
im flugzeug
ich warte auf
mein gepäck
ich übernachte im
hotel ich warte an der bushaltestelle
ich renne durch den wald ich warte auf
den zug
ich steige in den zug ein
ich arbeite als anwalt ich bin im
gefängnis
die autos stehen im parkhaus wir haben
geheiratet ich bin an einer
sitzung
wir löschen das feuer
wir drehen einen film
wir spazieren im park ich putze meine
zähne
ich stehe jeden tag um 7
auf
wir essen
zusammen
wir operieren den
patienten ich nehme ein heißes bad
ich bezahle
ich habe ein diplom bekommen
[Musik]